양자 중첩을 측정하는 건 동전 던지기만큼 무작위적이에요 — 그런데 이 비유가 어디까지 통할까요?
오늘 'Kiss in the Classroom'에서 함께 알아볼게요
'Kiss in the Classroom'에 오신 걸 환영해요 양자 컴퓨팅 관련 수업에서 만날 수 있는 핵심 개념을 쉽게 풀어드리는 영상 시리즈예요
각 영상에는 설명란에 링크된 인터랙티브 모듈이 함께 제공되니까 꼭 확인해 보세요 오늘은 양자 이론의 핵심 원리 중 하나인
중첩에 대해 이야기해요 우리 일상에서 물체는 항상 확실한 특성을 가지고 있어요 — 위치, 크기,
모양, 색깔 — 모든 것이 결정되어 있고 확실해요 우리, 즉 관찰자가 아직 측정하지 않았더라도요 그런데 양자
세계에서는 반드시 그렇지 않아요 양자 물체는 소위 중첩 상태에 있을 수 있는데,
고전적으로 허용된 여러 상태들의 중첩이에요 측정하면 그 상태들 중 하나로 무작위로 붕괴하게 되죠
여러 고전적으로 허용된 상태들의 중첩이고, 측정하면 그 상태들 중 하나로 무작위로 붕괴해요
중첩 상태를 측정하는 건 동전 던지기와 같아요 — 어떻게 떨어질지 미리 알 방법이 없죠
이 근본적인 불확정성은 심지어 Einstein도 불편하게 여겼던 양자역학의 측면이에요
그는 이 무작위성에 대해 "신은 주사위 놀이를 하지 않는다"고 유명하게 말했죠 하지만 우리가 보게 될 것처럼, 신은 사실 주사위 놀이를 해요 — 아니면 우리 경우엔
동전을 던지죠 게다가 이 동전들은 조작된 동전이에요 양자 중첩을 측정하는 게 어떤 면에서는 동전 던지기와 비슷할 수 있지만,
중첩 자체는 고전적인 확률 상태보다 훨씬 더 풍부하고 복잡해요
이를 보기 위해, 고전적인 동전이 어떻게 작동하는지 생각해보고 IBM 양자 컴퓨터에서 qubit으로 탐구할 우리의
양자 동전과 대조해볼게요 먼저 고전적인 동전이에요 꽤 간단해요
동전을 던지면 앞면이나 뒷면이 각각 50% 확률로 나와요 원칙적으로는 동전의 정확한 초기 조건과 정확히
얼마나 많은 힘과 회전력이 던질 때 적용됐는지 안다면 어느 면이 나올지 계산할 수 있어요
하지만 실제로는 어느 면이 나올지 사전에 알 방법이 없어요 그래서 우리가 동전 던지기를 고전적인 확률 상태의 대표적인 예로 쓰는 거예요
결과가 본질적으로 무작위인 거죠 제가 이 동전을 천 번 던져서 앞면과
뒷면의 수를 기록하면, 이런 모양의 히스토그램을 얻게 될 거예요 Y축에 횟수가 있고
앞면이나 뒷면이 될 수 있으며
히스토그램은 각각 약 500번씩 나온다는 걸
통계적 변동을 감안해서 보여줄 거예요 우리는 양자 컴퓨터의 qubit을 이용해서 비슷한 상태를 만들 수 있어요 동전 던지기처럼
qubit도 0과 1, 두 가지 상태로 측정될 수 있어요 qubit에 Hadamard gate라고 불리는 걸 적용하면
0과 1의 균등한 중첩 상태가 돼요 여기 그
circuit의 시각화가 있는데, 이걸 circuit 다이어그램이라고 해요 맨 위 선이
qubit이고, qubit에 적용되는 연산들이 선 위의 상자로 표시돼요 Hadamard gate는 이 H로
표시된 상자로 나타나고, 측정은 작은 측정 기호가 표시된 회색 상자로 나타나요 그게 측정값을
두 줄로 된 이 선, 즉 고전적인 비트로 보내요 qubit이 0과 1의 균등한 중첩 상태에 있으니까 측정하면 0이 나올 확률 50%, 1이 나올 확률 50%가
돼요 qubit이 0과 1의 균등한 중첩 상태에 있으니까 측정하면 0이 나올 확률 50%, 1이 나올 확률 50%가 돼요
이 양자 중첩 상태를 s = 1/√2|0⟩ + 1/√2|1⟩로
표현해요 s = 1/√2|0⟩ +
1/√2|1⟩ 여기서 각 계수, 즉 진폭이라고도 불리는 것들의 제곱이 각 상태를 측정할 확률이에요
그러니까 Hadamard gate를 적용하는 건 동전 던지기와 유사한 거예요 동전을 천 번 던져서
앞면과 뒷면 통계를 살펴본 것처럼, KCET에서 우리 양자 동전으로 비슷한 걸 할 수 있어요
통계를 샘플링하기 위해 circuit을 여러 번 반복하는 Qiskit의 기본 요소인 sampler를 사용할게요
천 번 샘플링하면 위 circuit으로
통계적 변동을 감안해서 고전적인 동전 히스토그램과 거의 동일한 결과를 얻어요 그럼 이게 다인가요? 양자
중첩이 본질적으로 동전 던지기와 비슷한 고전적인 확률 상태와 같은 건가요? 꼭 그렇지는 않아요 만약 그게 사실이었다면
꽤 짧은 영상이 됐겠죠 첫 번째 핵심 차이점을 보기 위해, 고전적인 동전으로 조금 다른 걸 해볼게요 그냥 탁자에 떨어지게 놔두는 대신
앞면이나 뒷면으로 착지하게 하는 것 대신, 동전을 던지고 공중에서
양 손바닥 사이에 잡을게요 이제 동전은 앞면이나 뒷면이 아니라, 앞면이 왼쪽이나
오른쪽을 향하고 있어요 그러면 논리적으로 이것도 왼쪽이나 오른쪽이 50/50 확률이어야 해요
우리 양자 동전에서 앞면이 왼쪽이나 오른쪽인지 측정하려면, 고전적인 동전에서 한 것처럼 할 수 있어요
다른 축을 따라 측정하는 거예요 양자 컴퓨터에서 표준 측정은 수직 축을 따라 이루어지는데
고전적인 동전의 일반적인 앞면/뒷면 측정과 같아요 하지만 양자 동전에게 앞면이 왼쪽인지 오른쪽인지도 물어볼 수 있어요
x축을 따라 이 두 상태를 플러스 또는 마이너스라고 불러요
이를 위해 Qiskit의 기본 요소인 estimator를 사용해요 조금 복잡하게 만들자면, sampler처럼 히스토그램을 반환하는 대신
estimator는 qubit의 어떤 관측량의 소위 기댓값을 줄 거예요
이 기댓값을 이해하기 위해, 동전이 앞면이 위로 나올 때마다 1달러를 받고 뒷면이 나올 때 1달러를 잃는다고 해봐요
기댓값은 각 동전 던지기에서 평균적으로 얼마나 벌 수 있을지 예상되는 금액이에요 1달러를 얻거나 잃을 확률이 동일하므로
기댓값은 0이 돼요 qubit에도 같은 추론을 적용할 수 있어요 x축에 대한 기댓값을 구할 때, 플러스 상태에 x를 적용하면
값 +1을 얻고 마이너스 상태에 적용하면 -1을 얻어요 그러니까 50/50 분포라면
기댓값이 0이 되겠지만, 실제로는 그렇지 않아요 — 기댓값이 +1이에요
즉 동전은 x축을 따라 항상 플러스로 측정된다는 거예요 이건 동전을 던지고
잡아서 항상 오른쪽을 향하는 걸 보장하는 것과 같아요 이건 왜냐하면 중첩은 단순한 확률 분포가 아니기 때문이에요 양자
상태를 어떻게 표현하는지 기억하시나요?
상태 s는 C₀ × |0⟩ 상태 더하기 C₁ ×
|1⟩ 상태와 같아요 각 계수들은 복소수예요 즉 실수부와
허수부를 모두 가지고 있어요 그래서 확률에 대해 말해주지만, 위상이라고 불리는 또 다른 양도 숨기고 있어요
× |1⟩ 상태예요 이 계수들은 복소수인데, 즉
실수부와 허수부를 모두 가지고 있어요 그래서 확률에 대해 말해주지만, 위상이라고 불리는 또 다른 양도 숨기고 있어요
어떤 계수 C는 이렇게 쓸 수 있어요
C가 크기에 이 위상을 곱한 것과 같고, 여기서 이 φ가
위상이에요 파동의 위상이나 파동의 마루와 골의 위치와 비슷해요 두 파동이 서로 위상이 같으면,
즉 마루와 골이 일치하면, 두 배 높이의 파동을 형성하도록 합쳐져요
이걸 보강 간섭이라고 불러요 위상이 이렇게 맞지 않으면
상쇄 간섭이 일어나 서로 완전히 상쇄돼요 위상이 우리 양자 동전에서 어떻게 간섭을 일으킬 수 있는지 보기 위해,
한 번이 아니라 Hadamard를 두 번 적용해볼게요 고전적으로는
이게 말이 안 돼요 — Hadamard를 적용하는 게 동전 던지기와 동일하다면, 이미 던지고 있는 동전을 또 던질 수는 없잖아요 하지만 양자역학적으로 어떻게 되는지 봐요
Hadamard를 두 번 적용하고 결과 상태를 샘플링해요
놀랍게도 더 이상 50/50 확률이 아니에요 결과 히스토그램은 모든 경우에 qubit이
0 상태로 측정되는 걸 보여줘요 두 번째 Hadamard가 qubit을 시작했던 0 상태로 되돌린 거예요
처음엔 조금 이해하기 어렵지만, 이건 양자 상태의 간섭 덕분이에요 하지만
실제 파동처럼 실제 공간에서 간섭하는 게 아니라, qubit의 추상적인 정보 공간에서 간섭이 일어나는 거예요
두 번째 Hadamard gate는 중첩의 0 부분이 보강 간섭을 일으키게 하고, 1 부분은
상쇄 간섭을 일으켜 사라지게 했어요 더 탐구해볼게요 위상은
위상 gate라고 불리는 걸로 바꿀 수 있어요 이제 Hadamard를 적용해서 중첩을 만들고, π 라디안의 위상 이동을 적용한 다음
두 번째 Hadamard를 적용해요 이제 양자 동전이 항상 1 상태로 나오는 것 같아요
π 위상 이동이 서로 위상이 같은 부분과 다른 부분을 교환해서
최종 상태가 0 대신 1이 돼요 이건 동전을 던지고 공중에 있을 때
항상 앞면이 위로, 또는 연산에 따라 항상 뒷면이 아래로 나오도록 보장하는 연산을 적용할 수 있는 것과 같아요
고전적인 경우엔 불가능하지만 양자의 경우엔 가능해요 이 실험들에서 우리가 배운 건
양자 동전의 이 새로운 능력이 위상 때문이라는 거예요 — 양자 중첩 상태는 가지고 있지만
고전적인 확률 분포는 갖지 않는 특성이에요 그래서 일반적인 동전 던지기는 중첩의 그다지 좋은 비유가 아니에요
이 위상에 대해 아무것도 말하지 않거든요 더 잘할 수 있을 것 같아요 동전으로 또 다른
실험을 해볼게요 동전이 앞면이 위로 향하도록 탁자 위에 놓여 있어요 뒷면으로 만들려면 그냥 뒤집으면 돼요
이건 NOT gate의 계산적 등가물이에요 두 번 적용하면 이 NOT gate와 동일한 연산을 만들고 싶다고 해봐요
이 연산을 NOT의 제곱근이라고 부를 수 있어요 NOT gate를 적용할 때 물리적으로 뭘 하는지 생각해봐요
예를 들어 x축을 중심으로 180° 회전시키는 거예요 그러니까 동전을 x축을 중심으로
90°만 회전시키면 NOT의 제곱근이 돼요 NOT의 제곱근을 적용했더니
동전이 끝에 서 있어요 이제 앞면이 위인지 아래인지 물어볼 수 있어요 음,
명백히 둘 다 아니에요 하지만 앞면이 위인지 아래인지 강제하기 위해 측정 과정에 단계를 추가할 수 있어요 이제
동전은 동일한 확률로 앞면이나 뒷면 중 하나로 떨어져요 원칙적으로는 어떤 방향으로 떨어질지 예측할 수 있겠지만
실제로는 본질적으로 무작위라고 볼 만큼 예측하기 어려워요 앞면이 왼쪽인지 오른쪽인지 측정하려면,
그 방향으로 눌러서 비슷하게 하면 다시
왼쪽과 오른쪽 50/50 확률을 얻어요 하지만 이 차원, 앞면이 앞쪽이나 뒤쪽인 경우에는
앞면이 이미 앞쪽을 향하고 있어요 그래서 100%의 경우 앞면이 앞쪽으로 측정돼요 x와 z
측정은 무작위 결과를 냈지만, y 측정은 항상 같은 결과를 낼 거예요 이전 섹션의
양자 동전 던지기 실험을 돌아보면, 이건 Hadamard를 적용한 후 양자 동전이 어떻게 행동했는지를
연상시켜요 qubit은 z 방향으로 50/50 확률로 0 또는 1로 측정됐지만
x축을 따라서는 항상 플러스 상태였고 마이너스 상태는 없었어요 이건 끝에 서 있는 동전이
공중에서 마구 돌고 있는 동전보다 qubit의 중첩 상태를 시각화하는 더 좋은 방법일 수 있다는 걸 시사해요
Qiskit에서 양자 동전에 NOT의 제곱근 gate를 적용해봐요 이 간단한
circuit이 있어요 그리고 estimator를 사용해서 X, Y, Z 세 관측량의 기댓값을 확인할 거예요 — 이건
제가 방금 보여준 것처럼 세 차원 각각을 따라 동전을 붕괴시키는 것과 비슷해요 X, Y, Z에 대한 기댓값은 각각 0,
-1, 0이에요 이건 우리가
고전적인 동전에 NOT의 제곱근 회전을 적용한 것과 같은 결과예요 사실 동전과 qubit 상태 사이에는 정확한 유사성이 있어요
이제 qubit 상태를 동전 앞면이 향하는 방향을 가리키는 벡터로 시각화할 수 있어요
동전 표면에 수직인 방향으로요 앞면이 위인 경우, 즉 0 상태는
양자 동전의 0 상태와 동일하고 곧장 위를 가리켜요 앞면이 아래 또는 1은 곧장 아래를 가리키고
0과 1의 균등한 중첩은 수평으로 가리켜요 양자 상태의 위상이 정확한 수평 방향을 결정해요
예를 들어 x축을 따라 가리키는지, y축을 따라 가리키는지, 아니면 그 사이 어딘가인지요
이 벡터는 Bloch 벡터로 알려져 있으며 단일 qubit의 양자 상태를 완전하고 유일하게 결정해요
이제 이 영상에서 본 모든 gate를 동전의, 또는 동등하게 Bloch 벡터의 회전이나 일련의 회전으로 재상상할 수 있어요
동전 또는 Bloch 벡터에서요 NOT gate는
x축을 중심으로 180° 회전이에요 0 상태 또는 앞면이 위인 상태에 적용하면
아래 상태 또는 1로 뒤집혀요 NOT의 제곱근은 같은 x축을 중심으로 90°인데, 앞면이
위인 상태에서 시작하면 앞면이 앞쪽인 상태로 회전해요 위상 gate는 Z축을 중심으로 φ의 회전이에요 앞면이 위인 게 Z축과 정렬되어 있으므로
동전에 아무것도 하지 않아요 Hadamard gate는 조금 더 까다로운데, 처음엔
동전을 공중에서 마구 돌게 하는 것과 비교했지만, Hadamard는 사실
다른 모든 gate처럼 동전의 제어되고 결정론적인 회전이에요 Hadamard는 90°
Y축을 중심으로 회전한 다음 x축을 중심으로 180° 회전해서 수행돼요 앞면이 위인 상태에 적용하면
앞면이 오른쪽인 상태가 돼요 그러니까 양자 중첩 상태나 qubit에 수행하는 어떤 표준 연산에도 무작위적인 건 없어요
모든 연산은 결정론적이고 가역적이에요 무작위성이 개입하는 유일한 때는
양자 상태를 측정하기로 결정할 때예요 양자 상태가 심지어 중첩 상태에 있는지 여부는 정말로
보는 사람 눈에 달려 있어요 이미 접하셨겠지만, 우리는 자유롭게 좌표계를 선택할 수 있어요
X, Y, Z는 세 개의 직교 방향을 따라 어디든 가리킬 수 있어요 그러니까
한 좌표계에서 0과 1의 중첩이 있다면, 새로운 좌표계 또는 새로운 소위
기저를 정의할 수 있어요 그 기저에서는 상태가 순수하게 플러스 Z 방향을 가리키고 따라서 중첩 상태가 아니에요
그러니까 qubit이 중첩 상태에 있다고 할 때 좌표계 또는
기저도 같이 정의해야 해요 이 모듈을 마치고 나면 양자역학의 신비를 모두 걷어낸 것 같은 인상을 받을 수도 있어요
결국 가장 이상하다고 여겨지는 측면 중 하나인 qubit의 중첩 상태가 사실 3차원 벡터만큼 간단하다는 거니까요
하지만 동전은 어디까지나 비유일 뿐이고, Bloch 벡터조차도
측정 결과의 확률을 계산하기 위한 시각화 도구일 뿐이에요 측정 전에 양자
상태가 실제로 무엇을 하는지는 알 수 없어요 — 그걸 확인하려면 측정이 필요하니까요 이걸 논의할 거예요
양자 상태의 진정한 본성이 무엇인지, 그리고 얽힘이라는 양자 현상이 어떻게
이를 밝히는 데 도움이 되는지를 'Kisd in the Classroom'의 또 다른 에피소드에서 Bell의 부등식에 관해 다룰 거예요 그 사이에,
qubit의 중첩 상태와 그 제어 방법에 대해 직접 배우면서 양자 동전을 다뤄보고 싶다면
설명란에 링크된 quantum coins 모듈로 가보세요 시청해 주셔서 감사해요, 다음에 봬요